how was it - for you you know sounds
like you're under 20 at this point and
you're in LA and Ventura just from the
short time I've been up here it's
beautiful it's a slower-paced I'm not
seeing angry drivers on the road like LA
and and I'm just wondering how that was
for you to go from such a nice place to
like this intense town and there's good
parts of LA - but exhilarating was it
because you know it is very sort of so
it's it's slower and and more calm and
peaceful but I was born in Philadelphia
so I was born a city kid so I like being
in the city you know and there's just
just there's just more there's a
trade-off you know if you're in Los
Angeles you did all necessary I mean Los
Angeles is actually a pretty beautiful
city in and of itself but the access to
that beauty is a lot harder than in
Ventura you want to go to the beach you
drive up to the beach park a car you go
be here you got a park and you have a
fine thing you got to pay the guy you
got it you know there's a lot of stuff
before you can actually just walk out
onto the sand but you know there's also
so much more available in terms of
culture and art and all these things
whereas in Ventura you know not as much
right but a beautiful place here
gorgeous gorgeous gorgeous place and you
know not devoid of art but it is a
different - different category you're on
the show for how long
Doogie Howser I was on - he who did we
run four seasons so I was there for
three I did a guest spot in the first
season and then they brought me on for
the second and then we ran for three
after
so after this show finished what was
your game plan what did you end up doing
I wanted to just do more I I wanted to
do film I really wanted to do film there
weren't a lot of things available that
fit what I wanted to do so that became
sort of a frustrating thing there was
also not a lot but a little bit of you
do a show like Doogie and then you end
up with this iconic character that Neil
played and so everybody sort of gets for
lack of a better term Duga fied so it's
like well we don't know if we want our
movie to be about Doogie Howser because
you're so known for that show obviously
it's not as bad you know for those of us
that weren't do I mean Neil Neil what
Neil's accomplished is amazing
you know because he successfully
overcame what was an iconic child star
role you know and it took a while for
people to see past duty and see Neil the
talent that he is but that was a little
bit of you know struggle I did a lot of
stuff in TV I did a lot of pilots that
didn't go I read for a lot of pilots
that did go but ultimately I just kind
of wanted to continue acting I don't
know that I had the game plan per se I
just was one of those actors that
depended on the representation and it
took me a while to figure out that if I
wanted to get something done that I
needed to take be more proactive take
matters into my own hands
and that took a while took a while to
figure that out
this is before sort of web series and
social media okay yeah this is way
before that all right so you you're
still staying in LA and were there any
points where you wanted to come back to
Ventura and you said I'm done with this
or no no I always knew that I wanted to
be working in this business ever since I
was a little kid even though I got
laughed at but you know I just I just
knew there had to be a way to maneuver
within this industry and I think the
problem that I had as an actor was that
I was I kept myself in a position of not
knowing things you know I I was I was an
actor who sat by the phone and waited
for the call and got upset because a
call didn't come and that's no one's
fault but mine yeah you know what I mean
you had there's a great one of my
favorite shows is a taxi taxi there's a
line in taxi where Alex is talking to
Bobby who's the actor in the show and
and and Bobby so upset and so frustrated
and he gave himself this amount of time
to make it in New York
and Alex says to him listen all I know
is that if you want a job you got to go
find a line to stand in you can't just
sit around complaining and that's what I
hadn't done at that time I was still
sitting around and complaining like
Bobby I had to figure out where that
line was and how to go stand in it and
and and change things and that's how I
landed on screenwriting
you